tout commence à pointe noire république
du congo j'ai vécu un an deux ans trois
ans quatre ans cinq ans 6 ans 7 ans 8
ans devant 10 ans 11 ans 12 ans 13 ans
et 14 ans comment vous résumer 14 années
dans cette petite ville au bord de la
mer
impossible alors j'ai choisi un souvenir
parmi tant d'autres
pour expliquer le contexte dans lequel
j'ai grandi
toute ma petite enfance
mon enfance
et mes premières années d'adolescence le
week-end on avait école le samedi matin
à 7h30 à cause des chaleurs
jusqu'à 11h30 après manger un sandwich
sur le pouce avec mes parents mes soeurs
et on partait à la plage lapointe
indienne
j'habite à pointe noire et la plage
s'appelait lapointe indienne mais il
faut savoir qu'il ya des plages partout
et on allait entre autres à la presse
indienne avec aussi des amis de mes
parents
est quasiment tous les week-ends
les week-ends de pont les vacances
scolaires en partie certaines certaines
parties des vacances scolaires on
partait dormir à la plage dans une case
avec un confort moderne bien sûr en
revanche je vous demanderais juste de
mettre de côté les gros clichés qu'on a
sur l'expatriation
certes le combo est une ancienne colonie
française il ya quelques clichés jolie
maison gros 4 4 tout ça évidemment nié
mais
tout le reste m'est et l'autre côté donc
en effet dans une jolie case
avec l'électricité mais
le dimanche en général on dormait samedi
soir dimanche jean les autres personnes
rentrées et moi j'avais cette chance que
ma mère travaillait pas avec
avec les amis de mes parents qui restait
donc que les familles les enfants
seulement non rester dormir le dimanche
soir est là il y avait un truc unique au
monde qui se passait ce sentiment de
privilèges santé - liberté c'est notre
temps dehors la nuit arrive
il y avait un mur et mourir l'amour la
marée monte et nous mettez sur ce mur et
eon se jeter comme des dingues
pas de crainte pas de peur pas de
limites certaines rade à respecter
évidemment car en effet on vit dans un
pays où on est pas on vient pas de ce
pays donc il faut s'adapter et moi c'est
ce que j'ai appris adaptation la
différence et la tolérance quand j'ai
compris que j'allais quitter tout ça
l'année 2014 ans je me suis mise à
dessiner sans cesse frénétiquement
j'étais très mauvaise mais je dessinais
vous voyez une oeuvre n'est ce pas une
grosse faute d'orthographe vous allez
voir ça je les fais c'est l'année où je
suis rentré en france je me suis mis à
dessiner ce que je voyais les cocotiers
et pamiers il faut savoir que cet arbre
là ça vient pas du tout africain y en a
partout mais ça va pas du tout d'afrique
et et ça pour moi c'est au monde 6 c'est
le symbole de ma rentrée de ma venue en
france j'allais dire rentrer me suis
jamais rentré enfants j'ai jamais vécue
suivi dix mois de l'année au congo de
malanje en europe en france
principalement mais comme j'ai je suis
franco allemande mon père est tellement
ma mère est française j'ai toujours vécu
dans ce triple culture donc même quand
on rentrait de les deux mois de l'été en
europe voilà je voyages et gel en
allemagne etc
je suis arrivé où je suis arrivé en
france comment vous dire nous l'avons
testé l'été ça allait à peu près je suis
un peu excité à la rentrée ok j'ai deux
grandes soeurs mais sûrement dit ouais
c'est pas mal tel sac à dos et la mode
même chose que je ne savais pas ce que
c'était on a mis nos codes donnons aux
autres codes il y avait des nouveaux
codes et mais un truc de dingue qui
serre qui arrive et c'est l'hiver il à
moi j'ai rien compris donc là je suis
entré dans ma période oignons
matin je me préparais je mettais en jean
les chaussures che débardeur j'allais
voir ma mère dont maman normalement
j'avais comme ça à l'école pourquoi j'y
vis plus comme ça à l'école et là je
commençais en fils et mes couches
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est je me
suis enfoncé tout doucement je me suis
lose les j'ai perdu tous mes repères
je retournais en afrique ponctuellement
mais il ya eu la guerre civile et ça a
été une des raisons pour laquelle sont
entrés les deux raisons il ya eu la
discorde entre mes parents et la guerre
civile
quand je suis rentré quand je rentre en
afrique quand je suis entré en france on
perd et si je vends ma fille que je
rentrais seulement avec ma mère et
ponctuellement je retournais en afrique
mais l'appareil tout avait changé plus
de repères me balader en ville avec avec
ma carte consulaire des choses qui
étaient pour moi impensable et plus
c'est depuis cette liberté là j'ai
entendu des centres kalachnikov chez vu
une chasse à l'homme j'ai vu beaucoup de
choses j'avais donc 15 ans et des
brouettes
et
il ya eu une chose positive
une décision que mes parents m'ont prise
une vision très importante ils ont vendu
la maison on habite et qui était en fait
c'est cette maison de vacances doutez
bien que une maison de vacances est pas
vraiment une maison dans laquelle on vit
même si elle était très jolie ils ont
dit ok on plaque tout on va vivre dans
le centre de nice on vivait dans
l'arrière-pays maintenant vers vis dans
le centre de nice je continuais tout
doucement à m'enfoncer j'étais
extrêmement extraverti j'ai toujours
beaucoup d'amis je fais du sport j'ai
continué à dessiner je fais ma danse mon
tennis mes trucs et machins j'avais mes
copines hyper important là dessus
l'adolescente classique et puis
à côté de ça à la maison introverti
totalement possible népal avec mes
parents mes soeurs vivaient à l'étranger
j'ai aussi des élus un peu comme une
fille unique pendant cette période il ya
une année entière j'ai pas vu mon père
donc bon mois la famille tard oui bien
sûr janin papa une maman mais bon deux
soeurs ou qui est super en finale tout
seul et en tout cas c'est le sentiment
que j'ai eu
donc nous voilà arrivés à nice et java
stanislas jeu pas baptisé the path
deuxième prénom
agnostique total j'arrive stanislas
lycée catholique ok super
je m'éclate gros éclate mais bon c'est
quand même mieux c'est plus petit ça
ressemble un petit peu à l'école que
j'ai connu
en afrique et on part en voyage scolaire
il y avait toutes les secondes pas
toutes les secondes 3 et avec mes
copines et là qu'est ce qu'on fait on
parle de garçon fait que ça on n'a que
ça à dire de toute façon cet âge là et
je tombe amoureuse je tombe amoureux
selon me vois pas de n'importe qui je en
italie vendredi david
est d'accord david
là j'ai montré que la tête j'ai fait un
focus sur la tête il faut savoir que
david hill énorme des très grands on
tourne autour on fasse ses fesses c'est
impressionnant c'est sublime et la jeune
révélation comme jeanne d'arc me suis
dit je sais pas comment je vais faire je
vais le faire l'art sera ma vie après ce
voyage
je décide de faire de choisir l'option
arts plastiques je sais pas dessiner
mais c'est pas grave on explique en fait
c'est simplement s'exprimer et trafiqué
avec ses mains je me dis ok ça me permet
de passer une troisième langue ça me
permet de faire un peu différemment
parce que le système scolaire s'aimer du
katif pour moi en effet ce n'est pas la
joie et puis il ya la philo
je découvre je me passionne pour le
romantisme
caspar friedrich
super game a aussi jeu j'y vais fort
mais à côté ça je suis hyper drôle je
suis plein de blagues mais je me fais
des bonds trip 2 ça va pas voilà ça
c'est mais ça ça me fait du bien donc je
vais j'oscille entre les deux en
permanence ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une
dépression une dépression tout
simplement c'est la première qui dure
donc depuis un petit moment
j'ai mon bac j'arrive même à avoir 20 en
option arts plastiques confirme les
choses petit passage à la fac je fais la
fête et puis je fais un petit con stage
mondiaux qui est quand même française je
connais mal la france moi j'ai jamais
été en bretagne de ma vie c'est après ça
que ça m'arrivait c'était il ya deux ans
tout le monde a été en bretagne je pense
dans son enfance je me dis ok donc
capitale de l'art paris londres new york
jeudi on va faire ça on va commencer par
paris paris c'est la liberté totale je
suis loin de ma famille personne de
aucune haumesser a voulu étudier à paris
voilà je crée mon petit cocon
je trouve ma ville d'adoption je choisi
cette ville c'est chez moi mais tu te se
passe à merveille et
ses études toute ma perdre à paris là
aussi quand j'ai commencé à travailler
symbolisée par une oeuvre d'art qui
navre d'arc de marcel duchamp
qui s'appelle fonsai
et là je me tiens un truc de dingue
c'est ce monsieur qui est donc français
pris un mur in war a renversé
et a dit c'est une oeuvre d'art et moi
j'étais fasciné complètement fasciné on
peut critiquer on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut mais il a eu cette idée
partir de là le design est parti il ya
plein de choses qui se sont passées dans
dans l'histoire de l'art dans notre
culture dans notre patrimoine mondial
et cet homme là elle m'a jamais lâché
parce que je sais aujourd'hui l'oeuvre
la plus brillante
qui reste sa peau brillante pour moi et
qui à mon avis restera longtemps
brillante
paris les études va bien mon master je
perfectionne
méconnaissance l'art contemporain super
je trouve un travail comme ça je
travaillais à la fiac comme ça parce
qu'aussi je suis doué quand même un
genou et je suis là au bon moment mais
je travaille je cravache et je sais
connais un peu ce que je veux je volonté
et puis en fait la fiac pour vous
expliquer simplement
ça a lieu au grand palais troisième
semaine d'octobre tous les ans depuis 40
ans il ya des stands
comme la foire de paris sauf que là
c'est des stands où bon ça vaut un peu
plus chers et des oeuvres d'art chaque
galerie un stand avec des oeuvres d'art
et
je voyage dans le monde entier hyper
content parce que je retrouve sa ce côté
cosmopolite je parle anglais tous les
jours tu me touches je suis dans mon
événement dans mon événement est dans
mon élément je mets un énorme couverte
sur tous les problèmes qui restent parce
que la blessure de l'afrique je rentrais
indice est joint en france marquées au
fer rouge
la minera en entrée en france je me suis
fait faire un tatouage dans le dos je
vais faire un petit soleil et ça passe
pas ça reste tous les 17 juin je suis en
deuil toujours en deuil et ça dure ça
dure ça dure ça dure
mais bon il faut continuer il faut
avancer et gélard qui m'amène en avant
je découvre je partage je rends compte
jean amoureux ce pour de vrai
la fia que j'y reste cinq ans et au bout
de cinq ans drôle d'idée j'ai 30 ans le
cap des trente mois ya plein de copains
à celui-là il était bien et était pas
mal je dis ok je quitte la fiac au mois
de juillet alors qu'elle a lieu au mois
d'octobre je crée ma société au mois de
novembre
je quitte mon copain avec qui
normalement
l'idée était on se marie on fait les
enfants toute cette histoire parce que
j'étais persuadé que le bonheur c'était
à deux c'est comme il ya pas vraiment de
bonheur entre mes parents je vous dis
non mais en fait si moi je vais créer ce
bonheur là je vais je le fabrique
absolument donc il faut être en couple
je viens rousse enfin je jvg sais je
sais je sais tout et
et là je me fais un cadeau
je deviens une onde aux girls band girls
et enfin le nom tant dogger c'est ce ce
que l'on donne aux jeunes filles
aux femmes qui sont atteints
d'endométriose
en 2013 qu'est ce que c'est lors de mes
trios ces maladies chroniques qui a
atteint une à deux femmes sur dix en
france j'espère vous avez bien entendu
six chiffres une à deux femmes sur dix
en france à partir du moment où on a nos
règles on peut avoir cette maladie un
peu ce qui se passe c'est qu'on a des
cellules qui sont
dans notre organisme et qui normalement
sont rejetés au moment des règles ce que
les femmes qui sont atteints
d'endométriose ce n'est pas le cas
elle reste à l'intérieur de nous en
général dans l'utérus
ça c'est le stade 1 de la maladie ya
quatre stades plus au monde dans le
stade plus en fait les cellules se
balade et vont grignoter vos autres
organes
j'ai écrit plein plein de mots pour
expliquer cette maladie et puis j'en ai
gardé quelques-uns la première ligne
cela veut dire
opération donc trompe ablation d'une
trompe en ce qui me concerne hamas en
attente gauche de l'ovaire gauche
tron droite à être toujours là il reste
un ovaire droit partiel
avant de faire opérer j'avais les deux
ovaires ensemble comme ça et un module
de 10 cm ici coller
aux expliqué en fait ça crée des
adhérents c'est ça déplace tous vos
organes à l'intérieur 12 donc forcément
ils peuvent plus fonctionner
suite les douleurs ont via cette fameuse
échelle un indice très bien on va
vraiment je suis monté à 50 sans
problème c'est une maladie qui
subitement on peut plus marcher
j'ai découvert cette maladie ce que j'ai
dit que j'ai quand j'ai su que je les ai
eus j'avais donc
trente ans
j'ai eu toute l'année 30 30 ans 31 à 31
ans s'est tellement développé moins chez
moi ça s'est développé très vite je vais
même plus leurs rapports sexuels on a 31
ans et j'avais pu ce plaisir là
m'a retiré ce plaisir la
laparotomie cela veut dire qu'on n'ouvre
le vent 32 donc j'ai une cicatrice qui
parle du pubis qui monte au dessus du
nombril
opération de trois opérations donc qui a
duré six heures
tellement c'était
le chantier l'attend
le meilleur moyen d'arrêter cette
maladie c'est donc depuis avoir ses
règles donc bien sûr vous l'avez compris
à cette maladie c'est l'infertilité ça
ne rend infertiles donc j'étais
ménopausées artificiellement
la là c'était la grosse fête
parce que j'étais une femme ménopausée
donc ouais super jeu tout un enjeu
ménopausées maman au site est ménopausée
donc c'était pas mal mais mêmes
symptômes chose je peux plus vaste il
ouvre la fenêtre fait quelque chose
lâche moi peu hystéro sur les bords
oui parce qu'évidemment donc c'est à ce
moment là où il ya eu la deuxième
dépression
donc qui amène opposé pendant une année
quand je suis je donc je me suis fait
opérer et quand je suis après
l'opération je rêvais la chambre
d'hôpital j'ai émergé
là j'ai dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
sonde urinaire
j'avais l'intestin qui ont je le savais
quand même hein je savais pas tout parce
qu'on ne dit jamais tout mais je savais
que j'avais mon intestin qui allait
sortir c'est ce qu'on appelle une stomie
c'est le fait d'avoir votre intestin 21
bout d'intestin qui est là qui étaient
là dans le vent donc génie toujours
cette cicatrice j'ai même un creux ici
j'avais une poche donc j'ai ma petite
sonde urinaire enfin j'avais poche donc
je vous laisse deviner un passeur et
cette poche
plus tout le reste je me dis c'est moi
je suis je suis je suis bionique c'est
un truc de malade faut savoir que
bien sûr il ya cette opération donc on
m'a enlevé beaucoup de choses sont mes
organes donc j'ai eu cette poche parce
qu'on manque d'amour son dentiste un
rebond amorcé un morceau de de vagins un
morceau de rectum
plein de choses
et
après l'opération
il est le moment du constat
la fa lui ai demandé des filles du
challenge fait un point
accepter d'être malade accepté de se
faire opérer ça m'a pris un an pour me
faire opérer j'ai eu tellement mal sept
jours alité non-stop pour de vrai je dis
là c'est plus possible il faut se faire
opérer
et puis ensuite il ya eu constat actuel
me suis dit les défis d'aujourd'hui qui
mais je vais continuer de travailler je
vais je vais pas arrêter je vais
continuer d'avoir ma société
et cette phrase le travail c'est la
santé le travail c'est la santé je la
comprenais pas je trouve ça débile
jeunes travaillent sur la santé ça veut
dire quoi le travail c'est la santé ah
j'ai bien compris puisque ce qui me
sentir tête de l'eau c'est d'avoir
toujours travaillé pendant cette période
là même si j'étais simon en arrêt
maladie et l'on perde où j'ai pas pu
travailler comme je le voulais je comme
j'ai tout décidé de tout mettre à plat
je me suis mise à plat qu'ont en commun
les sens on est à plat qu'est ce que
j'ai fait je pris mon ordinateur parce
que ça on peut le faire ordinateur tout
plat j'ai créé mon blog s'appelle marcel
et sa fontaine en hommage à marcel
duchamp la fontaine parce que donc
l'urinoir s'appelle funtime
et ensuite
des filles challenge futur avoir un
enfant dans deux semaines je vais savoir
s'ils trompent qui me reste les bouchers
ou pas savoir si je peux faire un enfant
naturellement ou alors si je passe pas
une procréation médicalisé assister
ça c'est
le gros challenge de l'année prochaine
on verra
pour tout mettre à plat
j'ai été dans une clinique psychiatrique
j'ai passé six semaines je suis rentré
au début je me suis dit ouais bon une
semaine
dans six semaines c'est énorme c'était
assez joli
au bout de ces six semaines la
juste avant de ma sortie j'ai mon ami ml
qui est bénévole paul tedx bordeaux qui
m'a appelé qui me dit ah tu sais je fais
ça je sais pas ce que c'était mdi le
thème c'est les ricochets la résilience
résidents je sais pas ce que ça voulait
dire alors j'ai dit j'ai cherché dans
dictionnaire jeudi bingo c'est moi et je
me suis dit en même temps c'est pas mal
son mode décembre et donc ça voudra dire
ça fera très exactement un an jour pour
jour
que je me suis fait opérer
quand je suis parti de la clinique je
dis merci à tout le monde personnel
soignant bien sûr sophrologue au psy que
je vais y est tous les jours
et je souris parce qu'il était
extraordinaire et je les adore penser à
eux
j'ai été donc dans le dans le bureau du
psy je les remerciais et je me suis
remercié en fait je me suis dit mais
reina il faut que tu te remercie
et je suis venu ici pour à nouveau me
remercier s'il ya six mois devant vous
pour me dire merci
et puis
je me suis demandé aussi je me demande
depuis quand vous vous êtes pas remercié
ou depuis quand vous n'avez pas
remercier quelqu'un aujourd'hui je suis
franco allemande congolaise en lames
parisienne d'adoption et inand de gueule
merci